et autres questions alors là je sais
qu'à ce sujet a beaucoup plu à jimmy
mohamed c'est très à l'aise avec ce
genre de sujet bull s'agit de nature
humaine en plus comme il est médecin
c'est son domaine un save walla est ce
que vous êtes projet la nature des
oiseaux la rivière tousart est carolina
font ça oui je pense bien sûr
et bien sachez ma soeur caroline j'ai
mis mes amis et vous téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent et qu'il est possible de
se marier et même d'avoir des rapports
sexuels avec la nature avec des arbres
avec la rivière avec lowey on a vu ça
dans cracks sur canal+
[Musique]
de mauvaises
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
alors je dois dire quand même que
j'adore monsieur poulpe bon alors en
tout cas c'est un sujet très sérieux
très réel jeu s'appelle l'écho sexualité
caroline alors vous vous adorez la
nature vous faites des trucs dans les
arbres sais pas quoi non mais c'est
votre truc
deux sont déjà 1 on n'est pas emmerdé
circé pas l'arbre qui vont ensuite de
passer un coup de fil ou tu fais quoi
ce n'est pas négligeable église avec la
deuxième chose c'est que moi c'est vrai
que j'ai souvent fait des stages de ce
qu'on appelle du langage du yoga
tantrique donc en fait c'est cesser
toute une c'est tout un rapport à la
sexualité que moi j'ai vu des gens qui
de très loin entre avait des rapports
sexuels parce qu'il ya un truc moins de
13 à dire qu'en fait souvent ça se fait
en duo ça se fait à deux et à distance à
distance et en fait l'idée c'est d'avoir
un orgasme seul sans rien faire juste
avec la connexion avec la nature la
respiration s'appelle un sextoy sa
chérie avait visiblement avec rien parce
que je savais que le chanteur sting
était a beaucoup parlé de ça avec sa
femme en donnant 10 ans qui faisait
l'amour pendant des heures et des heures
vers sens toucher mais juste avec ce
yoga tantrique de la balle est à peu
près l'air de badauds sinaï viejo filet
de ces accords donc donc vous ça vous
semble tout à fait possible
le whip musicaux très bien là-bas damien
j'ai posé la question à dernière damien
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces de
cette sexualité on est aux yeux le sujet
est ce qu'on peut tous constaté dans ce
sujet c'est que ces personnes qui sont
adeptes de l'éco sexualité ont tous un
physique disgracieux et ont donc des
rapports il entend un quart à bron pour
satisfaire leur libido en français
histoire n'était plus il est pas bien ça
fait rien
la chance mais la jeune femme qui a
procédé au mariage elle était mignonne
comme tout mais bon je suis là réussi à
te marier tout le monde peut le faire
elle dit
non